[Music]
it's not easy to remove a bullet from
the chest of a seven-year-old child
doctors at this Hospital in umderman
have been trying to save the life of
what the his father says he was shot by
a soldier while they were on a bus he
brought him here after trying other
hospitals which were closed because of
the fighting
[Music]
my son's injuries are severe his right
hand and left hand are rib on his right
and left and every time we discover a
new Splinter from the bullet I took him
to One hospital when a doctor there
brought us to here and helped us to try
to get him to recover
is one of dozens of patients who've come
to a known hospital with a gunshot
injury most arrive hours after being
shot because it's just not safe to
travel across the capital
fighting between Sudan's Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces has
resulted in many civilians being caught
in the crossfire at least one thousand
have been killed since mid-april and
thousands more have been injured
my friend was shot last night as he was
guarding his house as Ray bullet hit him
on the back we took him to One hospital
but it didn't perform operations we came
here and there were no doctors we took
him to a doctor in our neighborhood and
he couldn't do anything so we brought
him back here this morning and the
bullet was finally removed
the war has resulted in the closure of
many hospitals people in need of medical
assistance trickle into this hospital
every day and that puts a lot of
pressure on the medical staff here many
can't come in because of the fighting in
umdurman and for those who can make it
here to provide medical care there are
other challenges
staff here say they're facing a shortage
of crucial supplies and other
life-saving medical equipment
we're asking for the basic things we
Face a shortage in medical goals due to
the high number of patients with
injuries we don't have life-saving
Solutions we want those things to be
provided what we have is running out and
even though some organizations provide
us with supplies it's not enough we even
sometimes perform operations without
anesthesia because there is a shortage
in that too it's been nearly three
months since Sudan plunged into conflict
the patients young and old will continue
to arrive but doctors here fear they may
have to start turning them away if they
don't get the help they need Hebrew
Morgan Al Jazeera on durman
and Sudan's Army has told